desde que los seres humanos empezaron a
prestarse dinero ha surgido un problema
fundamental que sucede cuando alguien no
puede pagar no no
puede pagar no puede pagar la deuda que
tiene bueno antes de ver este problema
vamos a platicar un poquito acerca del
vocabulario la persona quien pide
prestado el dinero se le conoce como
deudor él es el deudor es quien pide
prestado pide dinero prestado
prestado
y como pidió dinero prestado es quien
debe el dinero entonces debe dinero por
otro lado tenemos al acreedor al
acreedor
y el acreedor es a quien se le debe el
dinero es quien prestó el dinero
entonces le voy a poner aquí que presta
presta el dinero
ahora sí que hacemos cuando un deudor no
puede pagarle la deuda al acreedor al
acreedor acreedor va que hacemos en este
caso bueno a la humanidad se le han
ocurrido muchas soluciones vamos un
poquito hacia atrás vayamos a grecia
antigua' le voy a poner aquí grecia
grecia antigua
antigua y los griegos tenían este
concepto de esclavo de préstamo esclavo
voy a poner esclavos de deuda de deuda
va entonces si en grecia antigua no
podías pagar te convertirás en un
esclavo de tu acreedor entonces bueno o
sea tú tenías que pagar tu dinero con
trabajo no sea arreglando el jardín del
acreedor o limpiar su casa tuvo tu
familia el chiste es que así entre todos
pagarán la deuda y entonces ya podías
ser libre a lo mejor para nosotros se
nos hace muy impactante pero bueno esa
era la solución de los griegos si pides
prestado y no puedes pagar ni modo te
toca ser esclavo de deuda para pagar con
tu trabajo
bueno vamos a avanzar en el tiempo
llegamos a una solución de europa
medieval que se siguió aplicando hasta
inicios y mediados de 1800
eeuu de hecho eso le tocó al papá de
charles dickens y que se le conoce como
la prisión de deudores lo voy a poner
aquí en prisión
prisión de deudores
deudores y básicamente la idea es que si
no puedes pagar una deuda te van a
encerrar así en una prisión más
literalmente una prisión tras las rejas
hasta que tu familia o tus amigos paguen
tu deuda entonces le voy a poner aquí
hasta que la familia que la familia o
amigos familia vale
en ciertos sentidos yo creo que esto es
peor que ser un esclavo de deuda acá
arriba al menos tienes la posibilidad
pues de cooperar con tu trabajo para
poder salir de tu deuda acá abajo no ha
dicho aquí abajo pueden pasar cosas feas
por ejemplo en mi situación tengo un
hijo de 10 meses si me meten en una
prisión de deudores él podría pagar mi
deuda claro que no voy a estar cubriendo
me en prisión por varios años antes de
que pueda entonces pues no se puede
hacer eso puede ser que le caiga mal a
mi familia que no tenga amigos entonces
tal vez una deuda de mil pesos me haga
tener una cadena perpetua lo cual está
terrible y de hecho le sucedió al papá
de charles dickens por eso por eso yo
creo que charles dickens escribía lo que
escribía pero bueno avancemos más en el
tiempo
avancemos más en el tiempo hasta que
llegamos a una época en la que somos más
civilizados y tenemos una mejor forma de
lidiar entonces ese va a ser el tema de
este vídeo y es la bancarrota en las
primeras versiones la bancarrota se
parecía un poco a la prisión de deudores
porque
más los intereses de los acreedores que
de los deudores pero poco a poco la ley
fue evolucionando para pues para darle
más derechos a los deudores de modo que
no tuvieran que enfrentar pues ninguna
de estas atrocidades entonces ahorita
vamos a ver la bancarrota déjame ponerlo
con este color rojo entonces voy a
ponerle bancarrota
rota bancarrota y aunque haya leyes de
bancarrota en varios países ahorita nos
vamos a concentrar en la bancarrota de
eeuu en la bancarrota de eeuu a nivel
personal de hecho en otros vídeos he
platicado acerca de la bancarrota para
empresas y es similar que si quieres
puedes después verlos bueno entonces qué
sucede o cuál es el contexto para la
bancarrota pues no sé imagínate que
estoy hasta el cuello de deudas de vos
cien mil dólares en deudas de tarjetas
de crédito no sé en una hipoteca que ya
no puedo pagar en un préstamo de auto es
un auto muy lujoso ya no me alcanza
entonces en eeuu tengo un par de
opciones puedo entrar en capítulo 7 o en
capítulo 13 aunque son un poco
complicado literalmente literalmente se
refiere a capítulos de la ley de
bancarrota entonces déjame pongo por
aquí capítulo
capítulo
7 vamos a empezar con este de acá el
capítulo 7 se le conoce como bancarrota
directa
por eso inyecta
indirecta va y no hay que dejarse llevar
por el nombre aunque se llame directa es
un proceso complicado es un trámite muy
engorroso pero la idea básicamente es la
siguiente vas con la corte de bancarrota
le dice sabes que no puedo pagar ellos
ven check and algunas condiciones y
dicen ok no puedes pagar te quitan todo
tu activo todas tus pertenencias casi
todas y pues lo que obtienen osea
subastando ese activo se divide entre
tus acreedores entonces después de eso
no debes nada verdad pero lo que se
tiene que pagar es que perdiste todas
las pertenencias casi casi todas verdad
a lo mejor te dejan ollas y sartenes o
un saco pero por ejemplo si tenías una
cuenta bancaria esa seguramente te la
quitaron que de por si no ha de tener
mucho dinero porque caíste en capítulo 7
pero no sé un anillo de diamantes te lo
quita un reloj rolex te lo quitan todas
esas cosas valiosas te la quite las
quitan
el juez la subasta las vende y lo que
ganan lo reparte entre distintos
acreedores y bueno al menos esto te saca
del ciclo de ver dinero y la pregunta es
ok eso suena bien a lo mejor debo mucho
más de lo que tengo porque no todo el
mundo lo hace
bueno pues o sea hay algunos peros por
ejemplo hay muchas reglas una de las
consecuencias una de las consecuencias
de entrar en capítulo 7 es que eso va a
aparecer en tu reporte de crédito por 10
años entonces aparece 10 años en reporte
de crédito reporte de crédito crédito
entonces está para pensarse o sea si no
puedes pagar en este momento a lo mejor
necesita pensar si ya existe alguna
posibilidad de que pagues de modo que no
se arruine tu historial crediticio por
tanto tiempo por otro lado si estás en
una situación desesperada pues pues
adelante ahora hay otros otros peros
porque no cualquier tipo de deuda se
puede
digamos perdonar a través del capítulo 7
por ejemplo los préstamos escolares
trescientos mil dólares y dices ah pues
que padre sea voy a tardar mucho más de
10 años en pagarlos entonces entró en
bancarrota este capítulo 7 no eso no se
puede
por ejemplo hay ahí hay otro tipo de
pasivos como los impuestos como las
pensiones todo este tipo de como de
deudas no se pueden perdonar a través
del capítulo 7 y por tanto o sea no es
tan sencillo decir me declaro en
bancarrota y ya no debo nada hay que ver
algunos detallitos entonces no es un
proceso sencillo pero a lo mejor te
puede servir en realidad lo que te
recomiendo es consultar a un experto
para ver tu situación personal
entonces capítulo 7 capítulo 7 es vasco
en la corte dice ya no puedo pagar te
quitan todo lo venden sales de deudas
pero entra mientras aquí en un periodo
de diez años de reporte crediticio que
te pueden afectar vamos al segundo
capítulo más común cuando la gente habla
de bancarrota personal que es el
capítulo el capítulo
capítulo 13 y este se conoce como
bancarrota por
reorganización y
organización vale muy bien la idea de la
reorganización es la siguiente tengo un
salario tengo un buen trabajo no soy una
persona irresponsable que gasto todo en
lujos sin embargo me surgió una
emergencia y no puedo pagar mis deudas
va entonces lo que le voy a decir a mis
acreedores es lo siguiente les voy a
decir te voy a pagar pero no te puedo
pagar ahorita de hecho por tu bien y por
el mío nos conviene postergar esos pagos
o estructurar los para pagarlos de tres
a cinco años entonces déjame escribir
eso en color rojo entonces digamos pagar
pagar de 3 a 5 años
entonces reestructuramos la deuda para
pagar en este periodo de plazo y además
no sé en vez de pagar de 50 mil te voy a
pagar 40 mil dólares en vez de que la
tasa de interés de mi tarjeta de crédito
sea de 20% la bajamos a 10% y mira en
realidad nos conviene a todos porque si
no aceptas eso entonces a lo mejor yo
caiga en capítulo 7 y todo el mundo
pierde entonces se hace el plan lo ssd
se hace una negociación los acreedores
aceptan y se paga una vez más estos anda
muy bien verdad puede ser que puede
llegar como puede ser que baja que
puedes llegar con una oferta así con tus
acreedores les inventas una historia
bonita de que tuviste una emergencia y
pues ya bajó mucho tu deuda pero una vez
más hay una penalización
ahora cómo está eso de la penalización
pues mira este dices o sea en tres años
de pago por ejemplo
en tres años de pago y entonces después
de que pagues esto todavía aparece en tu
reporte crediticio por siete años más
siete años y en reporte reporte
crediticio
crediticio entonces desde que inicia el
trámite hasta que desaparece de tu
reporte crediticio atrás transcurren
diez años justo como acá arriba justo
como acá arriba en el capítulo 7
entonces estos dos trámites no son cosas
para tomarse a la ligera en realidad si
son algo que te impactan por una porción
muy muy grande de tu vida pero es bueno
saber que existen en caso de que estés
en una emergencia en caso de que estés
ahogado de deudas para que sepas que
existe una salida aquí abajo entre 3 y 5
años acá es inmediata pero tienen sus
consecuencias en el reporte de crédito
bueno a lo mejor te has de estar
preguntando qué tan frecuente es esto y
pues investiga esta información antes de
empezar el vídeo así que voy a darte los
datos para que te des una idea de que
tan frecuente es déjame escribirlo por
acá entonces déjame poner por aquí
capítulo capítulo 7 aquí voy a poner el
capítulo 13
capítulo 13 ahorita vamos a ver que
cuando tenemos recesión aumentan mucho
los trámites de bancarrota
bueno antes de eso a lo mejor te da un
poco de curiosidad cuáles son los
capítulos intermedios
esos son poco comunes por ejemplo está
el capítulo 12 que se parece mucho al
capítulo 13 pero es para carl granjeros
para granjeros y para pescadores ellos
tienen un poco más de beneficio de
beneficios que la gente común porque
bueno eso está padre porque eso fomenta
la producción de comida también está el
capítulo 11 que aunque más bien se
aplica se aplica como para
reorganización de negocios y de empresas
pues puede aplicar para algunos
individuos que tengan un capital muy muy
grande así una gran cantidad de activos
y muchas inversiones pero bueno no se ha
habilitado la idea es que el 7 y el 13
son los que son más comunes a nivel
personal ahora sí vamos a ver los
números vamos a ver los números para que
no sé si es necesario que entres en una
de estas veas que no estás tan solo
entonces vamos a ver los números de 2007
de 2008
2008 y de 2009 y los números son hacia
entonces aquí en 2007 hubo 417 mil
solicitudes de bancarrota para capítulo
7 en 2008 hubo 560 mil observa aumentó
casi en un 20 por ciento y acá en 2009
hubo 800 19.000 solicitudes casi se
duplicó de las que teníamos en 2007
bueno vamos al capítulo 13 para ver cómo
está aquí fueron 277 mil más o menos
están en razón 4 a 3
más o menos luego aquí fueron 4 perdón
trescientas a 334 mil 334 mil
solicitudes en 2008 y finalmente de
capítulo 13 en 2009 fueron 300
370 mil aquí fíjate no es tan grande la
razón verdad de hecho aquí es menos de
la mitad 370 es menos de la mitad de 819
esto pues podemos pensarlo porque aquí
fue época de recesión entonces pues
realmente
o sea no es muy buena idea entrar en una
reorganización si te despiden de tu
empleo entonces casi todas las personas
que entran en bancarrota por por
capítulo 7 bueno espero que ahora sepas
más un poco acerca de la bancarrota y
que esto te ayude en el futuro si es que
necesitas tomar una decisión de este
estilo